si on fait trop merci bonjour bien je
vais vous parler de signer marine d'une
d'une opération qu'on a eu l'occasion de
faire c'est une petite entreprise donc
comme disait le présentateur qui a été
créée en 75 et le but de notre activité
bien entendu c'est les chaînes de
télévision les producteurs du cinéma et
les agences de communication comment ça
marche
asselah par le décor voilà donc nous
avons participé à de nombreuses
productions comme le grand bleu à qui on
utilise 60 films de long métrage une
cinquantaine de documentaires pour la
télévision et c'est là où nous sommes
intervenus vers l'année 1995 où nous
avons participé à un appel d'offres de
la chaîne américaine discovery channel
et le projet était d'éclairer les parts
du titanic sur une longueur d'environ 80
à 100 m donc ce n'était pas du tout
évident et on a été sous missionné parce
que nous travaillons nous travaillons
déjà avec discovery channel pour de
nombreux films d'archéologie sous marine
que vous avez peut-être pu voir la
télévision comme le phare d'alexandrie
comme toutes les fouilles qui on veut
qu'ils avaient été organisées avec
franck goddio qui est un archéologue à
ses collègues donc on a été
soumissionner on était la seule
compagnie française et il y avait à peu
près une dizaine de sociétés américaines
donc je vais vous rappeler en gros
l'histoire du titanic très rapidement
donc là pour faire partir le film
je peux tomber m la porte
ouais bon sinon bah donc c'était le plus
gros objets jamais construit par l'homme
qui pouvait se déplacer ne marche pas le
film là n'ont pas écouté on va on va
sauter le film c'est dommage
donc ce qui était intéressant c'est que
le titanic
vous savez tous histoire il s'est brisé
en deux il a coulé après son voyage au
njogu râle donc pourquoi est il ya eu
tellement de trait sur ce sur ce
naufrage c'est qu'il faut dire que à
cette époque il y avait une lutte énorme
entre la compagnie du titanic qui était
la star white et la cunard line pour
vaincre le ruban bleu c'est à dire le la
le temps que mettaient les
transatlantiques pour traverser les
océans et donc qu'ils avaient vraiment
mis là les constructeurs avaient
vraiment mis le paquet pour construire
ce bateau pour pouvoir aller très
rapidement
alors donc là il ya eu une presse énorme
au voyage inaugural
quand il est parti le battoir google
cette histoire il a rencontré un iceberg
il a coulé et il s'est brisé en deux
donc il s'est brisé en deux et les deux
parties ont coulé environ la partie
avant et s'est retrouvée pratiquement
intact pas intact mais disons en bon
état et il a coulé par trois mille huit
cent quarante mètres de fond et la
partie arrière elle a complètement
explosé parce que par le poids des
machines elle a percuté le fond après de
presque 100 kilomètres heure donc les
machines sont extrêmement lourdes
c'étaient les plus grosses machines à
vapeur jamais créé puisque les cylindres
qu'on peut voir les deux sur l'épave ici
faut dix sept mètres de haut donc
c'était vraiment la plus grosse machine
jamais produit donc l'idée de discovery
channel c'est d'aller explorer cet
arrière que l'on ne connaissait pas
puisqu'il ya eu d'autres expéditions
donc il ya eu trois expéditions qui ont
été montées pour pouvoir faire ces
images et il fallait donc trouver un
système pour pouvoir éclairer parce
qu'on ne pouvait pas éclairé à partir du
sous marin le sous marin il a des
batteries qui sont pour lui avec un
petit éclairage
mais quand vous devez éclairé à
une forme qui a canal surface et le
volume d'un immeuble de six étages
c'est pratiquement impossible avec un
sous-marin donc il fallait trouver un
système dont il ya eu un appel d'offres
auquel nous avons participé
donc voilà ça c'est une image sonar vu
de l'eau duo de l'avant donc c'est à peu
près là il fait à peu près 140 mètres de
long est là la coque fait jusqu'à 40
mètres de haut c'est absolument
gigantesque alors les américains ont
proposé donc on il y avait à peu près on
tourne étaient douze compagnies pour
soumissionner le projet de discovery
channel look les américains avaient
proposé donc une alimentation par la
surface avec un câble qui descendait le
bateau se maintenait au-dessus de
l'épave ce qu'on appelle en
positionnement dynamique
c'est là c'est un système qui est relié
par le satellite est pire que tout un
jeu délice le bateau arrive rester très
très stable sur le fond mais ce qu'ils
avaient complètement oubliée c'est qu'
un courant il ya un courant énorme qui
est sur 400 m 2 d'épaisseur c'est le
gulfstream cette époque qui fait 4
noeuds et aux fous on a un courant
inverse qui fait un noeud si bien que
positionner un éclairage
même en ayant le bateau stable c'était
pratiquement impossible d'arriver à
positionner les lampes à côté d'eux à
côté de l'épave pour les éclairer
sachant que les lampes ne doivent pas
être à plus de 10 ont maximum 10 15
mètres de l'épave si on veut vraiment
avoir un impact important
donc nous si les marines nous avons
proposé un système complètement
révolutionnaire qui est des tours
d'éclairage qui sont alimentés par des
batteries
donc nous nous avons pu organiser cette
tour parce que j'ai je connaissais une
entreprise à toulon qui sape a acquis au
pradet qui s'appelle gêné 6
et qui avec toute la technologie de la
commande acoustique c'est des gens qui
travaillent avec la marine pour les
torpilles pour les sonars et c'est donc
j'avais été voir le dirigeant jeudi si
on fait des temps d'éclairage est ce que
tu peux nous trouver un système de
télécommande acoustique avec des dés des
canaux différents parce que il faut
beaucoup de deux systèmes de systèmes
acoustiques avec quatre tours moi je
l'idée c'était de faire 14 faut le haut
niveau le off
il faut le positionnement parce que
quand vous larguer la tour il faut
pouvoir la retrouver donc il faut un
positionnement géodésique pour pouvoir
la retrouver et il fallait aussi un drop
line pour pouvoir la faire remonter des
cendres donc l'idée c'était le
sous-marin qui positionnent les tours
autour de l'épave et avec une bonne
acoustique on allume les tours et on a à
peu près une heure d'autonomie pour
filmer donc c'est tour elles sont elles
étaient faites comme ça alors il faut
dire que quand on a un gros bloc de
batteries avec trois tonnes de trois
plateaux elle fait à peu près 3 tonnes
donc vous avez à peu près une tonne 8 à
2 tonnes de batteries et le reste vous
avez les ballasts et les lampes et vous
avez les pings heures le problème c'est
d'arriver à trouver un système de
flottabilité
pour ces tours assez profonde alors de
3840 est il est absolument hors de
question d'utiliser ce qu'on appelle un
ballast à air comme les sous-marins
puisque à 3800 mètres forêts de l'air à
380 barre donc c'est absolument
impossible donc on a utilisé le système
des bathyscaphes qui avait été créée par
le professeur picard dans les années 30
c'est d'utiliser un flotteur remplie
d'un liquide plus le plus léger clos
c'est à dire le gasoil pourquoi un
liquide pascal titeux incompressibles
donc on a mis un gros ballon qu'on
remplit de 13 mètres cubes de gaz oil
qui lui
vient soulever la tour tenir la tour par
en dessous et de sous on met ce qu'on
appelle un guide drop c'est exactement
la technique des ballons dirigeables ses
terres que le guide d'europe c'est une
chaîne qui permet de stabiliser la pesée
de la tour très facilement
donc à partir en mettant un petit peu
plus de chaînes pour qu'elle soit plus
lourde
il va y avoir un certain nombre de
maillots qui vont se poser sur le fond
et la tour va trouver son équilibre sur
le fond donc à partir de là il suffira
de on avait mis des systèmes qu'on va
voir plus tard dans le film que je vous
montrais il va permettre de d'équipé
d'équilibrer la tour
jusqu au moment on n'est plus qu'un seul
maillon qui qui repose par terre et à ce
moment là la tour ne pèse seulement plus
rien donc le sous marin peut l'apprendre
qu'il a déposée et venir la positionner
tout autour du titanic dont je vous
avais il faut trois commandes acoustique
une commande qui fait le hall of pour
les lumières une commande d'un largueur
qui lui à un moment donné quand les
batteries sont vides et c1 on largue la
chaîne donc la chaîne elle est perdue et
la tourelle remonte en surface et après
il ya un poulain pinger de
positionnement parce que le problème
c'est la tour on l'a drop de la surface
et elle tombe sur le fond et après le
sous marin il faut qu il la récupère
elle tombe à peu près on peut pas tomber
à côté du titanic avec les courants tout
ça donc c'est un petit peu hasardeuse la
tour elle va tomber à peu près à 3 400 m
du titanic et après le sous marin et
vient il la récupère il la retrouve
grâce aux pinger hopping heures de
positionnement voilà donc les taureaux
ont été assemblés fabriqué en ici sur
toulon donc on a fait toute la
ferronnerie et après les batteries
venaient des états unis l'élan pour les
a fait fabriquer aux états unis les
ballasts on les a fait fabriquer toulon
c'était des balades donc des tubes en
titane dans lequel on mettait les
balades
et tout ça ça a été assemblé à saint
john qui est le port d'embarquement où
on partait pour aller sur le un petit
peu au sud des grands gourous et couler
le titanic
donc on les a assemblé à saint john donc
là vous voyez l'arrivée des cadres donc
les cartes sont venues de france l'aj
assange en assemblée les ballasts et ses
tubes en titane et dans lequel on
l'installé les ballasts les batteries
sont venues des états unis dont on est
sous un système de batterie sous il sait
des batteries de moto c'est des
batteries étanche des batteries au plomb
étanche et on les met dans des bacs avec
de l'huile
donc elles sont totalement en contact
avec la pression et comme les batteries
sont incompressibles puisqu'elles sont
pleines et l'huile
tout est le système est saoul il est
donc parfaitement étanche et et tenir la
pression
donc voilà donc les torts construite
vous pouvez voir dans tous les câbles
toute la communication des câbles entre
les batteries là on a les lampes donc
les lampes cd des verrines en quartz
était c'est aussi extrêmement complexe
parce que c'est des lampes de 1200 watts
hachémi et la verrine est en quartz
parce que à l'intérieur de la lampe
on a mille 400 degrés quand elle est
allumée et à l'extérieur l'ol fait un
degré et avec 3800 avec 380 bars de
pression donc on poussait pas du verre
c'est les verrines au ont été faites sur
mesure et fait spécialement pour ses
lampes
donc voilà là on est prêts on fait on a
fait les essais dans le dans le hangar
après on a on a sorti des tours et on
les a amenés dans le port de saint john
pour les essayer voilà donc les tours
ont été embarqués à bord de l'océan
voyageurs qui était le bateau
accompagnateur de dunes à dire qui était
le bateau support du titanic donc il
faut dire que pour le sous-marin nos
avions affrétés le nautile c'est à dire
le sous-marin d'ifrane r le tout l'eau
donc on avait une très très bonne
relation moi je dit georges travailler
mal à vif les nerfs pour les éclairages
les caméras du sous marin
donc on se connaissait bien on a on a
installé aussi toutes les commandes de
contrôle acoustique à l'intérieur du
sous marin pour les tours et il ya eu
une une communication entre mère et
notre société cinéma il est gêné si gêné
6 qui était à l'origine donc de s'est
construit de cette technologie
acoustique
ça s'est très très bien passé voilà donc
on a embarqué là vous voyez on installe
les pinger sur les tours voilà et après
on met à l'eau les tours là on fait la
mise à l'eau voyez là on remplit le
ballon de gasoil 13 mètres cubes de gaz
oil
c'est du gazole comprenez directement
dans la soute du bateau puis après on a
eu une fois que les log la mission était
terminée
on l'a remis gasoil dans le dans le dans
leur réservoir de 13 mètres cubes de gaz
oil ça vous donne une flottabilité
d'environ dans l'eau les torts fond de
tonnes donc ça fait à peu près de deux
tonnes de flottabilité et aux jouets sur
avec la chaîne
on arrive et on jouait sur 3 400 kg de
deux pour pouvoir travailler donc larvée
la mise à l'eau des tours voilà donc dès
que les taux ont été mises à l'eau alors
la mise à l'eau des tours à cause du
courant
elles se font toujours en amont du corps
entière que on a onze connaît exactement
la position du titanic en contrôle le
courant de surface il y avait 4 noeuds
de leurs 5 c 4 noeuds et à partir de là
on a drop et les tours à peu près à
presque 1 milles en amont du courant de
manière à ce que quand elle coule
elles vont couler elles vont pas coulé
droits qu'elles vont couleurs entraîné
par le courant est comme ça avec un peu
de chance elle tombe pas trop loin du
titanic donc c'est pour cette raison
qu'il faut absolument voir des pingers
pour pouvoir les retrouver après parce
que ans bassel devoir absolu bien
entendu donc là une fac là on a mis les
les taux pendant qu'on mettait les tours
à l'eau de l'autre côté à bord du daim
dire le navire d'ifremer j'embarque à
bord du sous marin et on va on mêle
sous-marins à l'eau et voilà donc là je
suis dans le sous marin le sous marin
c'est une sphère en titane qui fait à
peu près 5 m de diamètre et qui a été
construite pour pouvoir résister à
puisqu'il peut descendre à 6000 mètres
de fond il fait partie des trois sous
marins au monde qui peuvent aller à ces
profondeurs donc on est trois à bord il
ya un pilote et un navigateur et un
observateur ou un opérateur comme l'âge
était pour pouvoir manipuler tour là que
je vais vous passez donc le petit film
maintenant qui va vous montrer ce qu'on
a fait et je vous le commanderait au
fond de bührer je préfère que
voilà donc ça c'est le l'océan voyageurs
sur lequel nous avions les tours ont
enlevé la lumière baissée
voilà donc là on voit les tours là je
suis à côté du grand patron de le rms
titanic c'est lui qui était le manager
de toute opération
on a fait trois campagnes en 2 96 80 18
et 2003
c'était un très très gros challenge
d'arriver à construire ses tours là
juste avant la plongée on avait une
petite maquette de
les paravents et j'expliquais au
réalisateur de discovery channel comment
je voyais la disposition des tours du
toulouse les fans ma cape qui nous
permettait discutait rentrer
le producteur le réalisateur et
non
donc là georges schuler et
en patron m
la nuit
coté sur moi parce que en plus on avait
une liaison satellite direct de
discovery channel qui est remonté au
fond par fibre optique et on va lancer
sur le satellite pour pouvoir faire les
images on dirait sur l'horaire de prime
time de washington
voilà donc on fait la mise à nu soit
qu'un sous-marin absolument
extraordinaire
là une technologie française celle c'est
aussi difficile d'aller dans l'espace
que d'aller à 3000 mètres de fond tout
pour être totalement ignorée et c'est
vraiment une technologie formidable
la sphère aussi est en titane fait je
prends 14 cm d'épaisseur 5 m de diamètre
elle est pour une opérationnelle
similaire
donc 600 bars de pression
voilà donc pendant que on met le
sous-marin à l'eau ont rempli voilà on
met le sous marin il est tenu
voilà le sous marin est libre
donc le sous-marin parrein absolument
pas de ballast 1 alors voilà à bord du
navire il ya une salle dan sah
l'opération de contrôle ou au contrôle
la position du sous marin et on lui
donne des ordres de navigation voilà
donc là il ya une image de synthèse
c'est une vraie image aux vols sous
marin qui coule et qui descend faut à
peu près une heure pour descendre
jusqu'à 3800 mètres de haut
alors pendant ce temps là on remplissait
le dernier ballon 2
le gasoil de la dernière tôt donc on
prend le gasoil du bateau et on remplit
on met la dernière tour à l'eau il ya
déjà trois tours qui sont qui sont faits
là on peut voir lancre du geek drop sous
la tour non plus sous marin au bout
d'une heure de plongée arrive sur la
table
or c'est très impressionnant quand on
arrive c'est absolument
ces jeunes meubles
la voilà on arrive sur une tour et comme
je vous ai expliqué lall est positionné
sur pâques le guide drop mais la chaîne
plaît encore positionné sur le fond donc
tout autour voilà on voit la chaîne du
beat drop
on a mis des petits sacs
de 50 kilos de grenaille qui sont le
long de la tour qui vont nous permettre
en les coupant d'alléger la tour jusqu'à
arriver à avoir de qu'une chaîne
d'europe qui traînent par terre
localement la tour est en en
en équilibre parfait et sous marin peut
la déplacer et aller la positionner
on peut aller la positionner autour de
la coque
voilà donc ont installé les quatre tours
autour de la coque
on a fait en tout 13 plongée il a fallu
dix plongées d'installation des on a
fait 3 3 fois donc il fallait trois
plongées pour positionner les les tours
est une plongée pour finir voilà donc là
on a fait les premières images
on avait commencé par l'avant
mais surtout ce qu'elle importait
c'était l'arrière c'est la première fois
qu'on voyait l'arrière donc la voie là
vous voyez ça sedar c'est le cylindre
indécis l'inde la machine à vapeur donc
17 mètres de haut hopla le sous marin
est à peu près à 25 mètres de l'épave
après on se recule un peu pour voilà on
a à peu près à 30 mètres de l'épave ou
20 tours
à côté
on apprend que m
ouais c'est comme si vous deviez
éclairer un immeuble nous éclairer un
immeuble pour parfaire avec une nuit
avec une torche
là on est à à plus de 50 mètres de
l'épave
voilà cent quatre-vingt quatre étages du
le mans la hauteur de la machine sont
les plus
grande machine à vapeur jamais quelque
chose
et là on va voir un moment j'ai fait un
plan 2d cylindres on l'a fait un peu
complexe de moche on n'a pas le temps
pour pour tout voir
on sait les films qui sont qui ont été
diffusés par canal+ qui ont été repris
après par canal+
salle à l'arrière c'est un fatras qui
m'ont le plus rentable
on a beaucoup de mal à distinguer
quelques jours
le bateau s'est ouvert comme une boîte
de sardines quand il a coulé l'arrière
ses dires par la pression des courants
d'optique ou la santé
le pot s'est arrachée
et s'est retourné
comment comme vous ouvrez une boîte de
sardines avec
et donc le bateau est totalement
alors que l'avant lui la coulée bien
droit voilà là on voit
le cylindre
et casser votre fiston il est aussi lent
et casse est tombée
de l'envié l'âge
ces images personne ne l'avait vu avant
on n'est plus
pouvait voir avec les sous marins qu'une
petite partie
juste un petit coup non
donc après on est artiste on l'a
la partie avant
les humeurs d'éclairage et tours 1
et au bout d'une heure temps complet ont
drop l élite drop des taux remonter en
surface
à l'époque way
six heures on
pour une audition
nous dans le sous marin on restait 8
heures sur le fond
ça c'est le pont promenade des premières
classes
alors le qui voyez tous les stades mythe
des stalactites pardon qui sont le long
en fait le 2e l'épave est en train de se
faire détruire par des bactéries qui
sont qui mangent au métal c'est à dire
que ce sont des bactéries qui ronge
métal et ce sont les déjections des
bactéries que l'on voit et qui crache
ses stars y est on estime que dans 30
ans l'épave
ra complètement s'effondrer
là on voit là avant nous
en plateau
donc là on a compris à 50 mètres de
l'épave et
l'avant fait presque trop
là on voit bien une éjection de
bactéries du métal est complètement
rongeurs c'est tout un monde incroyable
de bactéries qui vit dans les abysses
colo l'on ne connaît absolument pas à ça
c'est une vue on voit lancre
avant on voit l'enjeu de rechange voilà
donc ça c'est complètement les travées
vous souvenez dans le fruit de cameron
quand caprio et à l'avant et
et j'avais fait cette image en souvenir
et
là on voit je suis normal voilà tout et
je vous remercie